this was an execution-style is also hate
crime from a neighbor our children spoke
about they were uncomfortable with he
came to the apartment more than once
condescending threatening and despising
and talking down to them as folks
continue to mourn the killings of the
three Muslim American students in North
Carolina there's also a huge
conversation going on right now about
whether this was over a parking dispute
as the police have initially said or
there was a hate crime so I wanted to
talk to dr. Omid safi who's a member of
the community there and also the
director of Islamic studies at Duke
University Omid what do you think even
if there was a dispute about a parking
space I think that's just the trigger
and the issue is really the underlying
dynamic but regardless of whether it was
over a parking dispute or if it was a
hate crime isn't the outcome equally
heinous the outcome is heinous and of
course there's nothing that we can do to
bring these three beautiful people back
the issue is about whether there is a
structure underwriting this hatred it's
15 years of dehumanizing Muslims as
human beings and constantly associating
Islam with a system of violence
extremism terrorism misogyny patriarchy
and it's that combination which is
produced this lethal context in which
all of us are living in right now do you
see any danger in using the word
Islamophobia with the alleged attacker
Hicks even though we don't know exactly
for sure what his motive is you know
there's a few things we do know about
him we do know that on his website he
identifies himself as a militant atheist
and the kind of New Atheists that he's
quoting the Richard Dawkins of the world
they say that they hate all religion but
there's one of them that they seem to
hate much more whether or not this meets
the legal criteria of a hate crime of
course is something that the legal
process has to investigate and determine
what can you tell me about the climate
for Muslims in the north
Carolina Chapel Hill area I think people
are feeling vulnerable and exposed in
some ways but we also know that we're
not alone and vigils like the one last
night matter these matter because you
saw hundreds of muslims being surrounded
by 5,000 or 10,000 people from the
community that came out to weep with us
to stand with us in the cold and and
just to show their love and support